موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لودوستن ان بلاده ولا تمنع
اوكرانيا من تطوير قدرات ذاتيه علشان
ضربات بعيده المدى وقال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن لا تسمح ولا
تشجعوا اوكرانيا على القيام بعمليات
عسكريه خارجه حدودها
وكان حاكم مدينه سيباستيل قد اعلن اسقاط
طائرتين مسيرتين قرب المدينه الواقعه في
جزيره القرم كما اعلن حاكم مقاطعه كورس
كار روسيه سيدافع مسيره الاوكرانيه مطار
مدينه كورس كوتهامه روسيا القوات
الاوكرانيه بتكثيف الهجمات بالمسيرات على
مطارات داخل اراضيها
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان بلاده
مستعده للعوده لمناقشه الضمانات الامنيه
اذا كان الغرب مستعدا لذلك من جهته قال
المندوب الروسي لدى الامم المتحده اين
موسكو مستعده للمفاوضات مع اوكرانيا طالما
ان هدفها وازاله الاسباب التي اجبرت بلاده
على اطلاق عمليتها العسكريه
على نقائد ما تعرف ابي قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه رفضه مقترح موسكو تسليما
النظام المناطق الحدوديه مع تركيا شمال
سوريا في غضون ذلك قال مصدر تركي للجزيره
الا انقر اعطت مهله للجانبين الامريكي
والروسي لاخراج تلك القوه من منبج وتر
رفعه عين العرب لتفادي عمليه عسكريه بريه
وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى
بلاده وهو مصممه على مكافحه ما وصفه
بالارهاب ومنع وصوله الى تركيا مضيفا انها
تملك القدره على تحقيق انتصارات لا
يتوقعها احد
وافق مجلس النواب والشيوخ الامريكيان على
ميزانيه الدفاع السنويه بقيمه
858 مليار دولار كما تمت الموافقه على
تزويد تايوان بمساعدات امنيه بقيمه
مليارات الدولارات على مدى الاعوام
القادمه
هذا واتهم وزير الدفاع الامريكيه لويس
اوستن الصين بزعزعتي الاستقرار في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وكشف اوستن ان
بلاده دعت اليابان الى الانضمام الى ما
سماه مبادرات تتعلق بتموضع قوات بلاده في
استراليا
اقتحمت عشرات الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
فجر اليوم وافاد شهود عيان بان دويا في
جارات وتبادل الاطلاق النار سميعه داخل
البلده القديمه خلال اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
رفعت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه قضيه اغتيال
الزميله شيرين ابو عقله برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وقالت الشبكه في بيان ان
الخطوه تاتي بعد اجراء فريقها القانوني
تحقيقا كشف عن ادله جديده تظهر بوضوح
الناشرين والزملاءها تعرضوا لاطلاق نار
مباشر من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
جهته قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى
بيد انه لن يسمح بسجواب اي من جنوده
الى اللقاء